[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la production de plastique pour
l'instant est exponentielle en deux
coups on en produit de plus en plus et
donc comme
finalement tout ce qu'on met
les fleuves tout ce qu'on jette arrive
dans les océans l'océan sans qu'on peut
infecter
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui est grave c'est
pas tellement le visible puisque
effectivement lorsqu'on traverse l'océan
ont pas trop de déchet mais c'est ce qui
est invisible à tout ce qui est tout ce
qu'on ne voit pas et créé qui se dissout
et qui absorbé par les
et nos marins par le plancton en fait
par la faune animale alors
les zones les plus touchées c'est
vraiment l'indonésie pta partie aux
séries à denezy alors là en train
d'explorer on va où j'apprends avec le
bateau donc on pense que
japon et la chine sont aussi des
endroits sont intacts et l'amérique
latine
pour ce qu'on en connaisse un truc la
côte entre l'équateur et puis lima est
effectivement aussi très affectés
c est compliqué mais c'est pratiquement
tout le temps tous les rivages leçon
peut-être un peu moins chez nous parce
que on a plus de possibilité de brider
matériaux et des déchets un peu moins en
articles en antarctique parce qu'il ya
personne mais le problème est le premier
grave
[Musique]
alors il ya des solutions de rentabilité
du plastique sont importantes parce que
c'est si on arrive à rentabiliser le
plastique effectivement ça permet
effectivement de déjà 2
faire travailler les collecteurs de rues
de créer une économie parallèle et pas
beaucoup de systèmes enfin celles qui
existent qui sont lus recyclage du
plastique pour fabriquer des plastiques
donc en fait c'est pas forcément le
meilleur moyen
là on est en train d'étudier plus qu'une
étude d'ailleurs parce que la chine
existe c'est une machine qui s'appelle
la bio grimm qui permet à partir la
combustion de n'importe quel plastique
de fabriquer l'énergie ça c'est vraiment
une solution d'ennemis voilà ça c'est
j'en ai beaucoup
le plus poignant
et qui me reste lourd dans le coeur
c'est la première fois où j'ai passé le
cap horn en course et répondent
l'équipage s'était lancé ces temps 77
c'est une belle histoire parce que
c'était ma première constant du monde et
la première fois que j'allais au cap
horn et que je n'ai ligue et dans un
endroit très très difficile avec des
maires très très belle à un moment où la
pollution était moins importante et
c'est une séance où l'aiea c'est un très
très beau signal jeunesse et l'équipage
[Musique]